I was into NYU film school who did you
bump into first was it Showalter Ken
Moreno I met the first day of school
because I was assigned to be roommates
with somebody he grew up with in Long
Island he was like this Italian guy from
Long Island and we were like Gotta Love
Camp basically Mo Willems who is now the
biggest children's book author on Earth
had started an improv group and a sketch
group at NYU and I joined that Todd
hollerbeck was in our group and he
decided we decided that we didn't want
to let new freshmen into our group so
Todd decided instead to start like a B
team at JV Squad and he left to start a
new group and then that became the state
that was the group that you know and
ever the main people from the state
Michael Showalter and Carrie Kenny and
Tomlin they all just showed up there
that became the that was like the
Freshman B Team group